so we have now about 20 minutes for the
Q&A session I'd like you to be really
focused asked one question only and then
we'll have another one question please
hi this question is for Val Val Morley
and you raised a very important point so
who you are first
I'm pavani Basu Allah I'm a second year
anthropology graduate student from Brown
and this is my question so you raised a
very important point about critiquing
the democracy credential so the initial
mandate when the Constitution was given
the initial mandate was like we have
come out of colonialism
let's have equality redistribution
recognition that that was the message of
Ambedkar and we came out with a very
strong Constitution and they were the
spirit of this these were the spirit of
the Constitution what happened later I
think Alan mentioned that the Dallas
move to the maxis of next lized movement
and they declared the Constitution as
about your document other strange is
that in the in the realm of affirmative
reservation the merit the discourse of
merit have become the new operative term
forecast discrimination of the order of
purity and pollution I'm talking from
anthropological point of view so my and
that's that's one thing so and another
just quickly the judiciary the what
happens to the democratization of the
judiciary if I was to do a and suppose
your Indian judiciary it's a new site of
we talked about in anthropological sir
change and continuity in caste so it's
like that it's the continuity of the
caste
there's no representation there's like
okay it's alright I'll just quickly run
to my question can I argue with my this
claim that the judiciary is like a very
exclusionary character and all all all
this thing that the Indian Constitution
now has become to use about the own term
of political fetish yeah chief justice
definitely I would not call the
Constitution as a fetish in the sense
that it it definitely seems to be part
of social processes that also Institute
in one way or another different
interpretations of it in that sense I
would still regard the Constitution as a
very important document I'm not sure if
there's anything more I can say on this
but I want the other panelists to have a
chance to myself Ramaiah I'm full right
whistling caller in Columbia I
appreciate all the three presentation
excellent presentation more specific
question to sivanna me that the the data
indicates that in the social science
institutions over 90% of the faculties
are from Brahmins and in the natural
sense ninety-eight percent faculty are
from the Brahmins and in bureaucracy
because of compulsive reservations the
situation has improved but large
majority of the Haven is positions are
vacant which means India since
independence have been governed
controlled by the married class Brahmins
but still they are not able to implement
most of these enclosing it mostly not
able to complete the implementation of
policy what does it reflect does it
reflect they don't want implement or
they are inefficient the other question
I think I should consider it both
because I won't I don't only restrict
the policymaking with a bureaucracy the
policymaking basically depends on the
information they get from the
bureaucracy with the collection of
information the process begin
also for examples a road to be
constructed there you keep in view first
whether we should buy cement from India
cements strike a deal either as a third
Road or cement Road that is the first
priority of the politicians so it is a
combination of inefficiency and also
apathy I should say in addition to
presentation like you know when the
government failed to show any interest
in giving lands to the dead but they are
showing very hyperactive this thing in
you know confiscating whatever meager
lands of Dalits in the name of special
economic zones and for the facilitating
the industrial corridors of the world
power companies this is the major
problem now the whatever lien landed the
Dalits they're facing you know they're
just throwing some amount of money and
then you know taking confiscating that
lands and you know with no justice at
all and this is a problem which we need
to focus in which is very contemporary
issue yes this is a comment directed
mostly on and I really appreciated how
you exploded very a great number of
myths one thing though that you said is
the that killed when many was the first
atrocity and that atrocities and violent
atrocities have been building over time
that's a very common narrative we don't
actually have the the historical
comparative data to say that for sure
but incidentally we do know that that in
in Tamil Nadu late 19th century when
Dalits did effectively challenge the
powers that be they were their their
charities were also burned they were
also murdered there was also mass scale
violence so the only thing we can say
for certain is that when there's been an
effective challenge and in the 1990s and
Tamil Nadu it's been linked to electoral
challenges there's been there's been
violence it's not correct
that previously it was just an
opportunistic beating and and you know
symbolic humiliation as opposed to now
it's violence the violence is always
there it's linked not to a change in
time but to cases of where people
actually assert themselves so it's just
a comment not a question though there
would be there would not be any sort of
distinction between this but if you
broadly look at the data you know and
the cases case histories of these
atrocities you would find that there is
a mark sort of qualitative
differentiation that could be made from
say 70s onward before seventies the
violence has been part of the little
life so there is no comment or required
on that but largely speaking they said
post 70s and even there is a marker post
90s the neoliberal phase they you can
see the distinction between the way the
atrocities were perpetrated and the way
the they happen now but you see the
impact of this so-called most strict
implementation of the sc/st prevention
of atrocities Act in you P do you see
the impact of this so-called stricter
implementation of the Act oh yeah
like rather Mohammed II had instructed
her instructed you should a circular
that crime against the elite would not
be automatically registered under the
atrocity Act unless approved by the
collector so that kind of thing has
happened in UK even despite that if you
see the static stage the numbers under
the atrocity I also have increased or
during the recent heinous not not to
distinguish maya this period but even
recent years
yeah I'm Mohan from Tamilnadu actually
basically I'm but I'm not i'm-a-comin
speaking guy basically but I am NOT
allowed to claim myself as a tunnel I
mean just I'm coming to
Balmoral a you know it's excellent paper
Ethne ization of culturalization of
caste this is how that the shudra
community which is becoming a sudra
supremacy community they are ruling the
people in the name like you know in the
name of ethnic group a tamil ethnic are
Dravid in ethnic like that so America
was not allowed to call himself as a
Murata speaking Marathi and sivagami she
was in a higher position in government
and she's Tamil speaking guy but always
she was called as Dalits right
not Tamil right and in an interview with
a Brahmin lady also she said why do you
call me a Dalek Moomin humor writer to
us but so it's like virgin yeah my
question is it's not a question actually
comment on ice paper by this the shoe
dress have become in the computer rulers
and using the attorneys ethnicity as a
big tool to rule the country thank you
but please stick to the rule you'll have
many comments to do and sure I have
plenty ask the questions one question
sir a quick one
there are plenty in the queue Yogeshwara
Ambedkar center for justice and peace
they're wonderful to all these three
papers the issue of atrocity is getting
from back to us as I'm until Tamela
brought it out so yeah and the question
is one second sir I travel three hours
to come here I need the time I traveled
T of us in the morning
you know Thank You Geoffrey a lot I do I
have a lot of respect for you but I have
to have my time the that the atrocities
are increasing and that needs to be
dealt with there is no clear-cut
solution that Government of India has
did I
one this committee to address it number
two the sister has brought excellent
points that half of the with 50 the half
of the world's child labor is sitting in
India half of the world child labor is
sitting in India 16 percent of the
population with 50 percent of the labor
that needs to be addressed and the
economic the development is not taking
place so the separate electorate and
separate settlements and separate
economic development are the only
solutions which I feel it I want to
commit to to address very thoroughly
thank you thank you very much underlay
there are questions also sanjay from the
new school I I mean save time by
treating yourself it's a very simple
question it's for the panel as a whole
if you could relate your analyses to
dull it party politics what impact if
any has that had because it seems to be
the elephant in the room so to speak the
lead politics also is encrypted by
neoliberal this market ethos you know
earlier times that just after a bit it
got co-opted by the ruling class politic
parties and now there there is no
independent kind of the liberal party
politics in X exists in India after this
globalization etcetera the market versa
even entered the politics it became now
the sort of very very black new kinds of
trade that happens in the name of Delhi
tortoise so there is no nothing to name
sort of delete party politics it just it
just tells the or confirms this some
some ruling party agenda in every corner
of the country yet I'd like to share
with you a piece of information I should
anong yesterday based on the CSDs
post-election survey well so that the
BSP in Uttar Pradesh got not only 85
Princip of the Jat Aves but also 64% of
the Duce odds and 61% of the other
Dalits which means that there may be a
ballot party in the making they're
cutting across different judges and
interestingly and this is the friend the
phrase you mentioned among cast cast
cast cut in two classes but classes now
are cutting into caste because even the
judges are not voting on mass for the
BSP when they are rich the richer you
are the more aggressive indeed you are
so this is this is probably a turning
point but I don't want to ask questions
I wanted to bring up the other elephant
in the room that many of you have
actually either written about or been
activists around which is Hindu
nationalism and the the forming of that
into a cultural phenomenon but and
simultaneously the recruitment of the
lids and tribals as foot soldiers for
the many atrocities that have been meted
out by particularly militant in the
nationalist groups how does that play
into the conversation that we're having
today thank you Smita I think broadly
speaking there there are at least two
arguments that have legitimized caste
for contemporary times one is a neo
Hindutva argument according to which it
is not that castes are about naturally
given orders because Hindutva these two
have suffered liberalism in some way but
they have definitely continued to make
the claim that caste is not about about
oppression so that is one line of
argument there's another line of
argument neoliberal argument which many
of us have heard and that is actually
that cars are very useful for capitalism
and India's most entrepreneurial not
just trading but even manufacturing cars
are
successful in a credit crunch capitalism
or a capitalism where institutions of
credit are not very well developed so
these are two broad things I I would
like to add a third one which is the
multicultural argument that cars are
good for multicultural democracy and
this ties in very neatly with the
Hindutva
that is now reorganizing hinduism along
the lines of main contradiction being
the lit versus non delayed and cause as
culture and let's all celebrate all our
castes with pride forgetting that caste
pride leads to atrocities can ask yes
this is a two ball morally I just have
this problem especially about seeing
cost as cultural communities are
culturalization of caste
I think cars are not cultural izing casa
rather politicizing that's very heart of
the politics of democracy in India is
that castes are becoming political
communities rather than cultural
communities if they're really becoming
cultural communities that goes against
the caste ok the celebration of Dalit
life definitely engages the Brahminical
life so it's that's not the way and
another thing I noticed that you know
very colonial anthropological way you
try to play the life of this Porter I
didn't understand the meaning how are
you different from a colonial
anthropologist intro th century and what
meaning you wanted to give I didn't
understand the meaning you wanted to
convey by you know if Porter sitting in
this audience he would not even have had
serious objections with the way in which
you brought out his life thank you very
much for the comments but let me try and
without being defensive clarify
something I think that when the Lit
class are talking about
it's very different from every other
caste Hindoo talking about culture which
is why I reserve the term
culturalization for caste Hindus Dalit
caste especially those who are extremely
politicized in an anti caste way draw
upon non class base intentionally
consciously non caste based things and
even Ambedkar talks about ethnicity I
think the term at mrs. Asian is proper
for that when I use the term
culturalization it is actually a D
politicization so I'm talking against
this thing called culturalization which
i believe is happening so for example
instead of saying and this comes to the
second question instead of saying that
we don't marry those other folks because
we actually find them in some way as a
different status especially lower status
we don't mind marrying the higher status
they say that we don't have a
convenience and a lifestyle gelling all
right in that sense they are definitely
talking about us having a different
culture from them now as far as my
experience goes and I talked with a
number of Potter's they definitely
engaged in very humorous ways with me
and maybe I come off as a colonial
anthropologist and I am using that in
deep irony there maybe it's so deep and
so subtle that it just falls flat
obviously it has and I will definitely
keep that in mind thank you apprehension
because from discrimination to
integration from discrimination you are
crossing borders and entering
integration what we are worried
basically is the exploitative nature
between communities okay I should be
working in your form and you are
creating atrocity and
torturing me that is a different issue
but we are not marrying each other that
is a separate issue because that is the
only thing because of course it is
that this is discrimination do away with
the discrimination is the first and
preliminary step and which I think we
need to pay more attention then on you
know culturalization of other cars and
how it is going to have an effect
because the exploitative nature is first
you know taken away from it then comes
the culturalization
I feel that student here in the history
department and I have a quick question
about what I hope is the third elephant
in the room which is the left and from
all your presentations especially mr.
Shiva kameez I was wondering if you know
given the shift in the past 15 years
clearly towards a very neoliberal frame
especially with the BJP and Congress and
BSP seems to be sitting out on that one
so do you think that then the questions
that you days and the concerns of the
lids can then only be addressed by a
Marxist am bitkha right approach or do
you think the two cannot be reconciled
it's not you know on the Dalit side of
course there is nothing could be done
they would be too willing to take any
allies but the Marxist with the limited
example I can quote in Tamil Nadu they
have never been talking about land
I cannot even quote one incident where
they would be asking for land all the
best the best that they could do for
Tamil Nadu is asking for one rupee more
wages are 50 paisa more wages for the
landless agricultural laborers are at
worst they can stage demonstration Sam
against American pepsi-cola and all so
never they stage they need the monster
ation for asking for land for the poor
living alone ballots so I don't think
you know right now they have anything
for India or a particularly Tamilnadu
because I come from Tamil Nadu so I
don't think there is anything but if
they have something probably will join
hands only communists who actually had
taken land struggle is at the
that bba s bba I realized that
whatever he had done it was only for the
urban deletes and he asked his followers
to take up land struggle and in
Marathwada in his lifetime the struggle
had happened and he was very pleased
about that later on the other side like
word another follower of Ambedkar had
taken up the same clue and created a
first countrywide land struggle in
balith history
now also communist movement is in
disarray the parliamentary communists
are absolutely bankrupt but there is a
there is a hope in the radical politics
in come communism in form of nook slides
as I indicated in my thing the
atrocities atrocities the supplement of
the list rain came from the Naxalites
inch under the incident had happened and
it was decided that we would eliminate
the landlord the landlord was eliminated
by pwg catters and it stands that in the
history in the surrounding of Challenger
there has not been any atrocity like
that so he's bagasse Jahan Abad region
of Bihar where belly started retaliating
and there has not been any incident of
that kind appearing in Jahan Abad so
probably elect in the Dalit emancipation
schema cannot be neglected just like
that
a major agitation you know calling all
the landless laborers for the abolition
of coati system that is abolition of
Zamindari system 1938 then he called for
the mating 20,000 people attended
whereas Gandhi had called for a meeting
1936 calling all those I mean does not
to pay tax to the British so it was
attended by 15,000 only another thing is
he was
one who organized the largest ever land
agitation in Hyderabad they at 1948 one
black people had mobilized on those days
without a no telephone or transport
facilities he told about one year the
whole of Andhra Pradesh to mobilize that
crowd just a quick thing I think I think
to try and address what you're saying
Sagami and also go back to what Rama is
saying sorry Jenaya Jenaya
you